five Jim is in Austin Texas hi Jim how
are you I'm doing very well thank you
and yourself just the same sir how can I
help well you always talked about
cutting up the credit cards and paying
cash now I'm in a little different
situation I was fifty thousand dollars
in credit card debt about fifteen years
ago it took me five years to get out of
that and ever since then I've been
paying my credit cards off in full every
month and I'm wondering why you don't
like that scenario well it's pretty
simple because you were $50,000 in debt
and a lot of people get there and you
can't get there with a debit card debit
card will do everything your credit card
will do except put you in debt and if
you're paying it off every month anyway
what does it matter
um it's just convenient I guess well so
is a debit card that's true
I carry a debit card on those I carry a
debit card on my business I carry one on
my personal account I have the money in
the account to pay the bill apparently
you do because you're paying it off
every month so yes they do it it's the
same difference I just the problem is is
that people accidentally end up in debt
they don't watch what they're doing and
the second part of the equation is and
Jim you you're not going to fall for
this as often or as deeply as some
people but uh but you and I both fall
for it a little bit even and that is
when you spend plastic versus spending
cash you spend more because you don't
feel the exchange occurring and there's
tons of studies that show that you're
going to spend anywhere from 12 to as
much as 60 or 70 percent more when using
a credit card depending on the type of
purchase the smaller the purchase the
more we tend to impulse or double up or
whatever but even on something a fairly
expensive item you'll add to it you'll
upgrade when you're using plastic and
you you know everyone spends some more
when using plastic than they do cash now
you're pretty conservative guy you're an
in control guy you learned your lesson
those years ago so you're probably not
like going crazy
overspending I'm not saying that but
even with your level of discipline and
so forth that's you still are
overspending I teach this stuff for a
living and I catch myself increasing the
tip when it's on plastic I which is fine
that's a nice thing to do a big tipper
anyway and you know I find myself you
know adding something else to the bill
not watching the bill as closely those
kinds of things and when you start
paying cash when you lay hundred-dollar
bills and Uncle Ben Franklin is looking
you in the eye as you're praying as
you're buying something you're spending
patterns change because you feel the
purchase and tons and tons of research
that says that and if you don't think
that's true then you would just be wrong
because now again I don't think you're
out of control
you're obviously very disciplined person
but that's the reason I tell people to
do that that's reason I do it this is
the Dave Ramsey show
you